[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Волинь
Острог]
Історія ця — дуже цікава!
Адже на той час я був єдиним доктором наук
у всій Західній Україні.
Почали мені говорити про Острог,
про цю історію,
що була знаменита Острозька академія, про яку я не знав нічого.
[Ігор Пасічник
Ректор Острозької академії]
Бо в Радянському Союзі про неї ніхто не знав.
Про князів Острозьких була ампутована
найменша згадка і пам'ять,
і про князів Острозьких, і про Острозьку академію.
У нас це забрали наші
східні чи західні сусіди,
підсовуючи нам
так звану «українську історію».
В нас забрали перемоги, інтелект...
А нація, яка не має, чим пишатися, —
не здатна стати нацією.
От чому ампутували історію
Острозького князівства.
Князь Костянтин Острозький  — унікальний полководець, що виграв 76 битв.
У князя з'явилася ідея заснувати
тут вищий навчальний заклад.
[Богдан Новак
Співробітник Острозької академії]
Тобто подібних закладів
до Острозької академії не було.
Він це зробив із декількох причин.
Передовсім йому потрібні були освічені люди,
яким можна довіряти.
Він хотів підняти рівень православної освіти.
Острозька академія — це своєрідна відповідь на реформацію, яка йшла у Європі.
І що ж собою являла ця сама Острозька академія?
Це було приміщення, де навчалися хлопчики — діти шляхти, яка була довкола князя.
Вони вивчали класичні науки для того часу:
граматика, риторика, діалектика, музика,
геометрія, арифметика і астрономія —
це базова шкільна освіта.
А потім переходили до вищих наук,
якими вважалися
філософія, медицина і богослів'я.
Поруч із академією засновується друкарня.
До Острога запрошується Іван Федоров — першодрукар.
1581 року у світ виходить знаменита «Острозька Біблія».
Академія була закрита у 1636 році,
Після смерті князя у 1608 році,
після смертей його синів,
не було кому академією опікуватися.
Після розпаду Радянського Союзу
група місцевих людей: острожан,
краєзнавців, працівників музею,
зініціювали процес відродження Острозької академії.
Це була руїна у повному розумінні цього слова.
Тут не було нічого!
Жодного стола, стільця, книжки, приміщення,
і я вже не говорю про кандидата наук.
Більше про Острог говорили як про психіатричну лікарню.
Мені навіть казали, що мабуть скоро потраплю туди,
бо погодитись на Острог і на «ніщо»  —
було смішно.
Це була найбільш фантастична ідея в Україні,
яка тільки могла прийти комусь в голову.
Відродити Острозьку академію
у богом забутому містечку,
незважаючи на те, що воно колись називалося «стольний град Острог».
Увійти у перелік найкращих вузів не тільки України, а й до міжнародних рейтингів.
Зараз займаємо позицію на дві сходинки вищу від Києво-Могилянської академії.
Принцип відбору колективу
був надзвичайно жорсткий:
по-перше, знання іноземної мови, бо друга робоча — англійська,
по-друге, ми підбирали виключно
молодих людей.
При всій повазі навіть до свого віку,
що молодь випереджує набагато:
у ІТ-технологіях та і в багато чому іншому.
Стажування закордоном —
це було обов'язковим.
Якщо не проходили, то ми направляли
на стажування у провідні університети.
З мене всі сміялися,
особливо ректори київських університетів.
Сміялися, що я набрав дітей на роботу, і що це за університет, що це — посміховисько.
Але тепер вони мені всі заздрять,
бо ця молодь захистила дисертації, вони стали кандидатами чи докторами наук.
Але найважливіше —
вони просунуті у міжнародний універсум,
в новітні освітні технології,
кожен читає авторський курс,
тому тепер це вже предмет заздрості.
Зараз через кожні 10 років змінюються вимоги суспільства,
змінюються спеціалізації, спеціальності,
тому необхідно на цей ринок реагувати.
А реагує на це молодь.
І тому я замінив абсолютно усіх деканів та проректорів — це все молоді люди.
Я своїм віком тягну їх назад.
А так середній вік — 34 роки.
Вік Ісуса Христа — вік творити!
В Острозькій академії не беруть хабарів
і не дають хабарів.
Якщо студент вихований, що він ніколи не давав хабара, ніколи не брав хабара,
він працюючи на роботі, довкола себе концентруватиме таких же людей.
Елементарна боротьба з корупцією і хабарництвом — це щоб керівник сам не брав.
Він намагатиметься, аби не брали інші.
Я абсолютно в цьому впевнений.
Так було з перших днів Острозької академії.
Нас стільки разів перевіряли, втім можна провести 100% опитування.
І ви отримаєте 100% відповідь:
«Ні, в Острозькій академії не беруть хабарів».
Коли мені говорять, що в Україні нема патріотів,
то я запрошую цих людей до Острозької академії.
Я вже казав, що тут не було жодної книжки,
а зараз маємо півмільйонну бібліотеку,
ми маємо найкращу електронну бібліотеку.
А ще нам підрахували, якщо б ми продали наші стародруки, які є в Острозькій академії,
то могли б побудувати три таких академії.
Уявляєте собі вартість?
І більшість тих стародруків
нам подарували люди.
Якщо говорити про мою мрію і мету,
то мене зараз цікавить українська інтелігенція.
Мене цікавить молодь, яка б за цю мізерну заробітню платню не тікала закордон,
і не виносила з-під пристарілих
італійців, поляків чи когось іншого,
а щоб, якщо молодь і їхала закордон,
то щоб працювала за своїм фахом.
Головний аудитор Люксембургу — випускник Острозької академії.
У п'ятірку найвідоміших економістів світу за журналом «Forbes»
входить наш випускник — Саша Талавера.
Він працює в Лондоні, але працює на Україну.
Україна може пишатися такими людьми,
але моя мрія, щоб 70% моїх випускників
нікуди не виїжджали,
щоб вони залишалися працювати в Україні
за цю мізерну зарплату
і будували ту державу, яку необхідно —
це головна мета.
Чим Острозька академія
відрізняється від інших вузів,
це тим, що дає не лише високі знання,
а передовсім формує
українського інтелігента.
Найбільше Україна зараз потребує провідників, довкола яких могли б згуртуватись люди.
Навіть на регіональному рівні треба людей, які зможуть будувати ту Україну, про яку ми мріємо.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Сценаристка
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]